secretary general i'm very happy to see
you good day
can you hear the translation is
everything okay
perfect mr president
mr secretary general i'm very happy to
see you
founding members of the united nations
permanent member of the u.n security
council russia has always
supported this universal organization
and we believe that it is not just a
universal organization but a
unique organization in its way
there is no other organization such as
this in the international community and
we
support in all ways the principles
it's based on and will continue to do
that
to us it sounds very strange the
statements of some of our colleagues
when they talk about the rule-based
world we believe that the main rules
are the u.n
charter and other documents adopted by
this organization and not some papers
written by somebody to
reflect their interests
we were also surprised
when we heard some of our colleagues
statements that
some
in the world
claim some exclusive rights because the
u.n charter
says that all the participants in the
international communications are equal
irrespective of their might and size
and their geographical situation
i think that this is the same as what
is written in our
bible
[Music]
all people are equal
under god that's why it sounds very
strange
those ideas that some
pretend uh claim some exclusivity we are
living in a difficult world in a
complicated world that's why we see
we have what we have we are working with
everybody
and of course the united
nations was created
at the time
following
crisis it's gone through different
periods in its development and just
several
years ago we heard that it's outdated
that it's not necessary
it was uh it happened at the time when
it was in somebody's way
uh it stood in the way of some countries
who wanted to achieve some place on the
world arena
there are no other organizations like
the un and we have to value it because
it was created after the second world
war to solve
such conflicts so we know that you're
concerned uh on the subjects of russia
conducting uh military operation in
donbass and ukraine i think that this
will be at the basis of our conversation
today in this connection i wanted to
note that
2014 this is an obvious fact you can
call it anything you want and you can
call any preferences or opinions about
people who were involved but that was an
anti-constitutional push and after that
uh the situation emerged with the
will
of the presidents of crimea and
sevastopol
who acted
effectively in the same way as uh
people who lived
and who live in kosovo did they decided
to become independent and then they
approached us and asked us to
join the russian federation the only
difference was that in kosovo such a
decision on sovereignty was adopted by
the parliament
but in crimea and sevastopol it was uh
taken on a
national referendum the same problem
was at the in the east of ukraine where
the residents of two territories at
least two territories
the constituent parts of ukraine didn't
agree with the results of the
coup d'etat but they found themselves
under pressure
including
through
the use of military force including
warplanes and heavy military equipment
this is how the crisis in donbass began
in the southeast of ukraine as we know
actually
after another attempt by the kiev
authorities to solve this problem
through military means
we
signed agreements in minsk
they were called the minsk agreements
that was an attempt to
settle
the situation through peaceful means in
dunbas unfortunately for us
in the course of eight years the people
who lived there were blockaded
the kiev authorities publicly announced
that they
would organize a blockade of those
territory they were not embarrassed to
say that it was a blockade even though
initially they
rejected that they were doing that and
they continued military pressure in
those conditions
after the kiev authorities
effectively publicly and i want to
stress this publicly
through
the
first
officials
that they didn't
intend to comply with those minsk
agreements to
prevent the genocide of those people we
had to
declare those
states as independent
it was
forced we had to do that to stop the
suffering of people who lived in those
territories but our colleagues in the
west preferred to ignore this and after
we
recognized their independence they
turned to us with the request to provide
military assistance to them because they
were subjected to military aggression
and
under
article 51
0.7 of the united nations charter we had
to do this and we launched a special
military operation
i would like like to inform you
that despite the fact that there is a
military operation underway
we still
expect and hope that we will be able to
achieve agreements through
a diplomatic
channel we are conducting
negotiations with
and uh in istanbul at the talks in
istanbul and you've just been
there i've
i spoke to
president
today that
you managed to
achieve a serious breakthrough
because the requirements of
international security of ukraine
our ukrainian colleagues didn't
link them with such uh concepts
internationally recognized borders of
ukraine
they
brought crimea
and um
recognized the republics of donbass they
made certain provisos there but
unfortunately after the achievements of
those agreements and
and after
our clearly demonstrated intentions
by us to create
favorable conditions to continue the
talks we came across
we faced the provocation in butcher
to which uh the russian army has nothing
to do we know who staged that
provocation how they did it and what
people were involved in that provocation
and the position of our uh negotiators
for
further settlement our negotiators
position changed radically after that
they uh
decided not to
move the issues of security guarantees
and
the crimean service topple and
donbass issues outside the
agreement they just rejected that and in
their drafts agreement
we
pointed that into articles that these
issues should be solved at the at the
meeting of the heads of states of course
we understand that these issues if we
move them
to the level of the heads of states
without solving them
preliminarily
in a draft agreement we know that there
will never be settled uh like that and
uh to sign under security guarantees
in that case without solving the issues
of territorial guarantees with respect
to crimea sevastopol and the donbass
republics we cannot do that
nevertheless the talks continue
they're being now held in an online form
but and i hope that
this will lead us to some
positive result
this is what i wanted to say
at the beginning uh i'm sure we will
have many issues in connection with the
situation maybe
we will talk about other issues i'm very
happy to see you welcome to moscow thank
you very much
mr president
thank you for receiving me in the
kremlin
it is
we need a multilateral
world order based on the u.n charter and
international law
rules which will be established must be
established with the consensus of the
international community and they should
totally
reflect the international law
i strongly believe in the international
law in the u.n charter
and this is why
we differ in our views on the situation
which take place
i understand that the russian federation
has several
claims
and complains
about the situation in ukraine and also
in connection with the european global
security
i've held many positions in my life i
remember that i had the possibility to
meet you
when i worked
when i was the head of the
the eu
the government of portugal we even met
in the same room maybe
i understand your
consent
but
in our view this uh
must be sold used on various tools
suggested by the un charter
we strongly believe
that the violation of the territorial
integrity of any country
fully contradicts the un charter
and we are deeply concerned
in connection with what's happening uh
now
and we believe that
there was an invasion into the territory
of ukraine
nevertheless
i arrived in moscow with a pragmatic
approach
deeply concerned about the humanitarian
situation in ukraine the united nations
is not part of the political
negotiations
we've never been invited or allowed to
take part in the minsk
express this to predicament
we support the dialogue between the two
countries and we support turkish
goodwill in promoting this approach but
our main task
is with regard to the
humanitarian situation in ukraine and we
want to improve it
this is exactly why
i held a meeting today with minister
sergey lavrov
presented two proposals
implement our proposal
which we've presented
to clarify the situation with regards to
humanitarian corridors in humanitarian
aid and that cooperation was
fruitful but
honestly we come across situations when
uh
ukraine uh establishes one corridor and
russia establishes another corridor and
the situation is such that those
corridors do
ukraine will discuss the situation so
the
is will be truly effective
so that nobody will have an excuse to uh
sabotage those corridors on the other
part we understand the difficult
situation in mariupol
again
as for this situation
i would like to say that the united
nations is prepared to fully mobilize
its logistical
capacities it's human resources
together
initiative we have to work together with
the
armed forces of ukraine and russia so
that so once and for all this problem
will be solved
this will be an initial operation to
evacuate civilians from there
still works
russia is permanently
used that it doesn't
conduct this evacuation on the other
hand russia has
announced the establishment of corridors
which are not being used and we're
together with the red cross with the
ukraine and russia we are prepared to
assess the situation and within
two or three days this will allow us to
evacuate those who want to be evacuated
of course this is a voluntary process
on the other hand
many people
and a
large
area of the city has been destroyed many
people are still there
and they are in a difficult situation
they want to leave the city
some want to leave for russia
others want to leave
for the territory controlled by the
ukrainian authorities
and together with the red cross
we will use all our resources to work
together
with the authorities of russia and
ukraine
in order to create this opportunity to
guarantee the evacuation of those people
this will be a longer process
we have to
establish
more concrete forms of cooperation but
we're really interested in this we
pursue only one aim is to
alleviate the situation of those people
and to alleviate their suffering as i
already said this is the opportunity
to um
red cross and to do this process uh
totally transparent so that nobody will
accuse the other party that something is
not taken in
sorry
i am really well uh
aware of all the
documents of the international courts of
the u.n on the situation in kosovo i
remember very well the decision of the
international court
which says that
when implementing the right to self
determination this or that territory
any country
does not have to
ask for permission to
declare their sovereignty to the central
authorities of that country
that was written in relation to kosovo
and that was the decision of the
international court
and that decision was supported by
everybody
i personally read all the comments
from the legal and administrative and
political bodies of the united states
and the european countries everybody
supported that
if this is so
then the republics of
the nets people's republics and the
lugansk people's republic
have the same rights
applying to the central authorities in
kiev to declare their sovereignty
because the president exists
is this so
do you agree with this
yeah first of all
mr president the united nations doesn't
recognize kosovo
but the court the court recognized this
let me finish
the court recognized it
if this is
this president has been created then the
republics of donbass could have done
the same way having done this
and
and then on our part we got the right to
recognize them as independent states
many states in the world have done that
including our opponents
in relation to kosovo many countries in
the world have recognized kosova this is
a fact
many states many western states have
recognized it as an independent state
we've done the same with the relation to
the republics of donbass but after we
did that
they
applied to us with a request to provide
military help to them
against the country
which was conducting military operations
against it against them we were entitled
to do this
under article
51.7 of the un
so we will discuss about this later i
want to um comments on the second part
of your statement about margie opal
the situation is complicated there
and tragic
he said that military operations were
taking place there no the military
operations have ended there there are no
military operations in mariopol they've
stopped
chest
parts of the armed forces of ukraine
which were deployed in other industrial
areas they have surrendered
almost
thirteen hundred people surrendered they
were taken prisoners but
they were even more of the more there
are some wounded there
they are kept in normal conditions
wounded
pers since are receiving qualified
medical assistants
[Music]
there are no military direct military
operations there
yes we're here
from uh
the ukrainian authorities that there are
civilians there
in that case
the
servicemen of the ukrainian army must
release them
they're acting as terrorists in many
countries as the isis in syria they are
hiding behind the civilians this
the easiest thing to do is to release
them
you are talking about
the russian humanitarian corridors that
they're not working no they lied to you
they're
working
with our assistance
more than a hundred thousand people left
marijuana 130 or hundred and forty
thousand people left mario pal and
they're free to go anywhere
some people want to go to
russia some to ukraine anywhere we don't
hold them back and we provide
all possible supports and assistance to
them
civilians can also do the same if they
are there at the other style works they
can just leave
an example of civilized attitude
to those people is obvious
everybody can see that just talk to
those people who left
what would be easier
for
the troops
there
the representatives of the nationalist
battalion just
leave just release those people it's a
crime to heal to hold their people as a
human shield if they're
there we're in touch with them
works they also have good examples
their comrades in arms have left and
lay down their arms
more than a hundred a thousand people
thirteen hundred actually and nothing
has happened to them
if you want to see uh uh
esteemed
secretary general and the
representatives of the red cross
and the united nations
how they're being kept and where and how
medical assistance is being provided to
wounded so the wounded we can
help you this is the easiest solution
of this difficult
or seemingly difficult issue let's
discuss this